[Music]
a three-masted sailing ship has left
london for an extraordinary voyage after
a brief stay in ports the trip started
in sweden and will end in china with
stops along the way the gutenberg is
powered only by the tide and wind sails
by the skill of her crew
raymie and asensio went on board
with cannon booms cracking the air
the world's biggest wooden seafaring
ship makes itself known
a 21st century replica of an 18th
century trading galleon that sailed to
china for the swedish east india company
bringing tea and porcelain back to the
west
the ship is now retracing that journey
to the east
on its port of call to london this week
we met the captain
it was
very nice to sail with you and volunteer
crew from around the world and stepped
back in time to a sailor's life of masts
riggings cannons and pirates
i just killed him
and this is a cool but admittedly
somewhat terrifying point of view from
above the ship we're about 80 feet up on
this platform from where the sails are
unfurled but it goes even higher 160
feet up and i'm told that on a
clear day on the high seas you can see
up to 35 miles away
when you look around this ship
first you think wow
dylan wickstrom from san diego is the
only american crew member on this leg of
the journey he sailed with the gutenberg
several times since he first laid eyes
on it a decade ago
everyone is working together to keep the
ship moving forward
eating sleeping playing laughing crying
bleeding together you know
it's a labor of love for the crew many
of whom switch out at each port
now it's time to say goodbye again
with future stops in lisbon athens
singapore hong kong and then finally
shanghai
stefan bjork owns the guttenberg
china these days in the eyes of much of
the west is seen as something
to be reckoned with
maybe we can be a a peace broker
i'm the feeling that the trade is
uniting people you have to be close to
your friends here whether it's black or
white or yellow or if you're christian
or if you're whatever i mean you have to
be close together
i think ship is a very good project for
putting people together
the gutenberg and its message of
community and connectedness is scheduled
to arrive in china in the fall of 2023
for cbs saturday morning raymond
ascencio london
that thing is huge it's amazing it can
even like
float on the dims that's a long trip i
was just thinking that's a really long
doesn't arrive in china until fall of
2023.
people are trying to get away you know
what i'm saying
that is getting away from you're working
while you're away yeah